Get your hands in the air Zoom!
The whole timeline's breaking down.
Tonight, we change the future
Eddie? I'm about to be born. Am I breaking timeline
rules by being here I wasn't gonna
say much but it's fine you're fine
You didn't think I was gonna miss how this
all turns out did you surrender flash
for the last nine years I have watched
the people I love suffer and die
my wife is about to give birth to
our child I'm trying to save the
timeline and eddie's life everybody down
then you need to believe in the impossible
Hey there kid.
Barry's Life Is Mine any last words
I've got three. Run Barry, Run.
tell me what to do accept our power
And end the legacy of Barry Allen forever
Welcome back everyone
The Flash series finale is happening they
just released a trailer a lot of you been
asking for me to do a video for the ending so
I'll explain what's going on in case you tuned
out years ago because the show's been going on
for almost 10 years but big reminder this is
the end of the flash like the very end of the
TV show also explain what's going on with the
Flash movie because I know a lot of you are
holding out hope that Grant Gustin was lying
about being in the actual movie having a cameo
scene maybe some surprise crossovers happening
in the future if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos but in
the trailer you can see the Flash fighting pretty
much every single one of his biggest most iconic
villains from previous Seasons the Harrison
Wells reverse flash they also just had the
original Matt Letcher flash on the show recently
I'll explain that twist because it also paid off
a moment from the very first episode in a couple
of finales in earlier Seasons where he kept going
back to the night that his mother died and seeing
other versions of himself in that moment Teddy
Sears is back as Zoom savitar's back and they're
finally doing Eddie Thon is a version of cobalt
blue from the comics which fans have been making
theories about since the end of flash season 1.
like this has been around for almost 10 years of
all the fan theories that they've ever tried to
pay off this is probably the longest running one
that they're paid off Grant Gustin also revealed
how the ending of The Flash changed and it turns
out that the original ending for the show that he
had wanted was actually my theory that I came
up with back during I think like season two or
season three it was a long time ago my original
theory in the ending the Grant Gustin originally
wanted wound up being way more hardcore than the
ending that the show is going with but at the end
of the previous two episodes they explained that
the original eddiethon who died at the end of The
Flash season 1 sacrificing himself to get rid of
reverse flash had actually been reincarnated in
the future year 2049 corrupted by the negative
speed force in the cobalt blue crystal Force
like he's taking in the negative speed force here
becoming a version of cobalt blue in this scene
here in the cobalt blue crystal here is meant
to be a version of the blue flame cobalt blue
uses in the comics they just changed the cobalt
blue backstory for the TV show in the comics it's
Malcolm Dawn he's meant to be like this long-lost
brother to Barry Allen so obviously the TV show
explanation is quite a bit different but the real
main villain of the finale even though you have
all these villains coming back is the cobalt blue
Force that's manipulating all these villains like
turning eddiethon into cobalt blue and it's the
thing that brings back reverse flash savitar and
zoom across different points in the timeline and
claims that it's existed since the dawn of time
and at least as far as it's told Berry its goal
is to wipe him from all of existence so that he
never existed so that he can't just run into
another universe or hide in the speed force
which exists across pretty much all of space
and time across all universes the only thing
they haven't revealed yet because the cobalt
blue force keeps possessing people kind of
like the blue flame from the cobalt blue Comics
they haven't explained if that force is actually
just a person pretending to be this Cosmic being
the way that savitar pretended to be the god of
speed but it was just another version of Barry but
the majority of the finale like the fun part is
The Flash versus all of his previous films like
they brought all these actors back pretty easy
prediction to make that he'll wind up stopping
them and find a way to remove the cobalt blue
Essence from Eddie Thon corrupting him so that
he goes back to normal he's not all crazy from
being resurrected then find a way to trap the
cobalt blue crystal for all time or destroy it
in some way the whole deal with the Matt Letcher
reverse flash the original reverse flash in the
scene of Barry going back to the night that his
mother died again is meant to pay off the first
episode because originally in previous Seasons
when he went back and he was starting to pull
Flashpoint or he was getting ready to try and do
a flash point there was yet another flash another
version of Barry from a different timeline that
reached out and told him no don't do it hell no
he let his mother die and then we
continued with previous Seasons so
what they explained is it the berry
that told him to not pull a flash
point that told him to chill out was the
current version of Flash from season nine
one
you saved yourself and let me kill her instead so
was them trying to bookend that moment by saying
that Barry got a day with his parents like he
spent the entire day just hanging out with his
parents without them knowing that he was their
real son it was meant to take place on the day
that reverse flash originally killed his mother
so the whole day reverse flashes taunting him
messing with him trying to savor his victory
because reverse flash originally intended to
kill the young version of Barry Allen so that he
would never become Flash but instead what Barry
winds up doing is saving his younger self
so that reverse flash can't kill him and he
kills his mother instead so the big Revelation
here is that reverse flash originally had not
intended to kill Barry's mother that was sort
of a backup plan after Barry saved himself so
in a way it's a bit of a bootstrap Paradox where
the flash is the reason why he became the flash
because originally reverse flash was going to
kill him before he could become the Flash and
obviously reverse flash got stuck there and I
had turned into the Harrison Wells version of
himself where you see during season one and so
like after this moment Barry gets pulled back
to the present by the cobalt blue Force but this
version of Matt Letcher reverse flash just goes on
to the beginning of season one like its reverse
flash at the beginning of his timeline meeting
with Barry at the end of his timeline the other
big thing happening in the finale is that Nora
came back from the future but she's also being
born in present day like you can see Iris West
is super pregnant about ready to pop Carlos Valdez
did say that Cisco will not come back because it
was a scheduling conflict he wanted to come back
and do the finale but he was just busy filming
something else and couldn't do that and this is
what Grant Gustin has said about the ending that
sort of coincides with my theory from many many
years ago when I thought about it ending there
was a theory out there that Barry would sacrifice
himself to keep the speed force alive and become
the lightning bolt that inevitably struck him
and create this full circle moment and I Eric
um was very opposed to the idea and really wanted
to see a happy ending for Barry and Iris what my
original theory was is that they should actually
just do a version of the comic book story it was
a really small story but it was essentially Barry
Allen becoming the bolt of lightning that gave him
powers in the first place so the whole idea is
that this was tied to crisis on infinite Earth
in the comics in Barry sacrifices himself during
that comic book storyline to stop the anti-monitor
and he seemingly dies but what really wound up
happening is that he traveled so quickly that he
turned into the bolts of lightning that originally
gave him Powers becoming the flash so the whole
idea in the TV show is that it would have been
really cool for them to bookend the series where
he basically creates a Time Loop where he becomes
the bolts of lightning that originally gave him
Powers so like the show season one to season 9
is a big loop it was cool to find out that Grant
Gustin also wanted that ending for a while but the
current flash showburner said that they changed
that they wanted to give him a happy ending I
think just because they wanted a happy episode of
TV for a serious finale I don't know if that's
better you can decide like you watch and you
decide whether or not you wanted the more hardcore
ending or the happier ending so do not expect him
to die at the end of the finale Grant Gustin did
say that he would always be happy to come back and
do Cameo scenes and crossovers as his version
of The Flash and other TV shows or movies and
speaking of movie cameos The Flash movie is coming
there's a bunch of Multiverse cameos in that movie
A lot of people wondering would he have a cameo in
the film he claims that he doesn't but I'm hoping
I'm really hoping that Grant Gustin is just lying
about that and there'll be a big surprise and he
will actually be in the movie in some way no yeah
there's been a lot of rumors out there for a long
time and no one's like come out directly and
asked me like ever like you know on the record
the rumor right now if it's to be believed is the
teddy Sears did have a cameo scene like there is
a cameo from The Flash CW TV show but it's Teddy
Sears and he's actually playing a version of Jay
Garrick not a version of Hunter zolom and zoom
which seems like the weirdest Cameo to go for
like if you're gonna have a Flash CW Cameo scene
why wouldn't you go over the Grant Gustin version
of flash just to pay off the crossover from crisis
on infinite earth when Ezra Miller came from the
Justice League Universe to cross over so really
holding out hope for that I haven't seen the movie
yet so I can't say whether or not he's actually
in there or he's not in there hopefully they'll
find some Multiverse way for him to have a cameo
scene in one of James Gunn's upcoming rebooted DC
movies because obviously there'll be like another
10 20 50 years of DC movies Grant Gustin could
show up at any point during that the same way
that John Wesley's ship came back from the 90s
what I'll probably do is I'll make a video for
the finale after it airs next week so be sure
to check out the finale even if you've tuned out
for years like if you haven't watched The Flash
since like season three just go ahead and watch
the finale because it is the last episode ever
I've got a bunch of other videos I'm working on
they just dropped some more Flash movie trailers
so of course I'll do videos for everything
everyone click here for my brand new Flash
movie trailer and Easter eggs and click here
for that new Blue Beetle trailer in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!